The influencers Who promoted FTX are now
being sued for over a billion dollars in
Damages and I want to talk about it
we're not only speaking to a lawyer but
even one of the people getting sued meet
Kevin Graham Stefan Andre dick minority
mindset Brian Jung Financial education
Jeremy Tom Nash and bit boy crypto are
all defendants in this lawsuit but
before we get into it I have to do
something
I never thought I would do on this
channel
I have to defend a certain person on
that list a guy I have been very
critical of on this show I'm talking
about bit boy crypto
I know I can't believe it either what
many people don't know is that he turned
against them and get this months before
the collapse he started warning people
about FTX we are going to be Crossing
out ftt and Solana these are going to be
going out of the portfolios these coins
are dead to me same payment free Drew
dead to me Brett Harrison you are dead
to me FTX you are dead to me you are
despicable and I'm disgusted by you in
every way shape or form everybody's
going to be on that track oh my gosh he
said that way back in September he said
he's disgusted by sandbagment freed this
is Big Boy crypto guys he's the Jim
Cramer of crypto and yet somehow he made
one of the greatest blind call outs of
all time and it's so remarkable that I
actually want to show you yet another
clip of him doing this because I simply
couldn't believe it when I saw it
they're playing games with people's
lives and that's not right time to
expose FTX and SPF what what they really
are what can I say that video is a month
before FTX collapsed and to be clear I
am not claiming that big boy is some
Oracle I think it was luck but
understand that he's one of the most
widely ridiculed crypto influencers
everyone has dumped on this guy for
years for bad calls but here we are
watching him get FTX the biggest con
more correct than even the most beloved
Financial influencers so it just doesn't
make sense for him to be in this lawsuit
and besides you're not supposed to sue
bit boy crypto anyways he sues you when
you make fun of him alright sorry I'm
I'm trying to defend him here but um I'm
not used to this strange turn of events
where the villain has become the hero
but either way with that out of the way
I want to talk about the rest of this
lawsuit basically the rest of these
influencers are accused of promoting FTX
and getting paid for it it also accuses
them of not conducting adequate if any
do religions allegedly these influencers
played a major role in the FTX disaster
who hyped the deceptive FTX platform for
undisclosed payments now look none of
this is really surprising we talked
about this back in November and it all
feels inevitable the whole reason FTX
was so popular is because of the amount
of money they dumped into these
advertising campaigns everyone I know
was offered one of these deals either
way it's pretty logical to see that
without people willing to take the money
and sell FTX it just couldn't have hurt
as many people and already we saw a
similar class action lawsuit come out
against arguably the biggest promoters
Tom Brady Larry David Kevin O'Leary and
so this just seems like the next logical
step targeted at smaller promoters
albeit Financial education influencers
in particular so although these guys
don't have as anything close to Tom
Brady's popularity the argument here is
different it's that people look to
people like Graham Stefan and meet Kevin
in a different way than they looked at
Tom Brady if Tom Brady promotes some
penny stock you'll think nothing of it
but meet Kevin Graham Stefan Andre chick
Financial Jeremy all they do is do
Finance all day long they even have a
podcast they called Millennial money
which was sponsored by you guessed it
ftxus and is now deleted and the point
is they position themselves as experts
and I think that's the real juice of
this lawsuit in contrast to say like the
Tom Brady lawsuit the only analogy I can
think of is like if someone tried to
sell you a pill that was going to help
you lose weight and the two people
promoting it is Jack Black and Dr Oz
okay let's say you take the pill and
develop uncontrollable vomiting who
would you actually be mad at you know
you could say Well Jack Black's more of
a star But ultimately obviously the
answer would be Dr Oz because he's
expected to know better and to do due
diligence and the reasonable assumption
is that Jack Black couldn't look into it
even if he tried because he's not an
expert and so I think that component
probably will make a massive difference
I'm certainly not saying everyone who
promoted FTX who didn't know anything
about Finance should be let off the hook
I think it's a huge problem either way
that non-experts can chill Financial
products I'm just saying it's worse if
they are experts but to make my position
even more explicit I don't think
influencers of any kind should be
allowed to promote these investment
products I think there's a huge downside
to it and very little upside I think you
oftentimes end up hurting people because
it's impossible to give broad Financial
advice in a responsible manner to a
massive audience you don't know but on
that note you might say well hang on a
minute Stephen I'm with you on not
selling Financial products but uh they
weren't selling that they were selling
FTX right or FTX us and this is where
things get a little tricky because yes
there's some truth to the fact that FTX
us was a platform but on that platform
they were also selling Financial
products you see you could buy what was
called a yield bearing account or you
could put your money in it it's where
they offered you eight percent a year
and this wasn't just FTX this was FTX us
and that's a problem because well this
type of account is probably an
unregistered security to avoid going
into too many details let's just say
several different accounts like this
have been targeted by the SEC as being
unregistered Securities and the FTX earn
accounts would be no different so this
is where the lawsuit gets its claim that
these influencers may not have just been
promoting a scam they may have been
promoting an unregistered security Now
to be fair to these influencers these
earn accounts were in a strange gray
area according to the website the FTX
app earn is available only in permitted
jurisdictions which would appear to mean
that the United States of America was
not allowed to have these accounts but
in typical Sam bankman freed fashion
what they said on their website wasn't
actually true you see these accounts
were actually available to us investors
as seen on a screenshot from their own
app quote FTX earn rewards are available
for us users on a promotional basis and
admittingly this was confusing to a lot
of people a redditor said FTX earned for
U.S customers is incredible but very
poorly marketed and then complains that
it almost feels intentionally hidden
which should have been a red flag uh and
maybe it was but it was there and like
it or not if American investors put
money into this earn account we could
earn eight percent a year because of one
of these influencers they may have sold
an unregistered security which would be
bad not just for the person who put
their money there but also bad for the
influencer I mean look it's it's all bad
it's just legal Jiu Jitsu to kind of get
to the obvious ultimately this story is
about people getting hurt promoters
getting paid and now they're getting
sued for it to which I say good although
not everyone believes this particular
legal strategy is going to hold water I
asked legal eagle a well-known lawyer on
YouTube what he thought and he was
doubtful about its chances and basically
the entire case rests on a part of the
Florida law that the plaintiff's claim
connects the endorsers to FTX I'm very
skeptical of this the section in
question extends liability to any
director officer partner or agent for
the seller if they personally
participated or aided in the making of a
sale and if you're on YouTube or if
you're a celebrity endorser you're not a
director of the company you're not an
officer you're not a partner and you're
not an agent you're not able to act on
behalf of the company you're just
basically contracted to make a statement
for most of them it relies on a bear
allegation that they were quote paid to
endorse FTX and then there is a
subsequent allegation where
so wishy-washy it says quote it is hard
to imagine that anyone who has done
business with FTX including paid
endorsers would not have personally
witnessed one or more of the
deficiencies identified by Mr Ray he's
the guy who's in charge of the
receivership of FTX and bankruptcy and
all FTX endorsers have extensive
business dealings Beyond FTX and surely
would be able to identify business
practices that are unusually problematic
now as a legal matter I don't think that
that really changes anything as a
factual matter it's just completely
false that a celebrity endorser or a
YouTuber would have any insight into the
inner workings of FTX that the public
does not have that's just not the way it
works though at the same time I wouldn't
want to be these YouTubers either who
are going to have to pay thousands and
thousands of dollars to their lawyers to
defend against what is quite possibly a
meritless lawsuit I don't expect this
particular lawsuit to go anywhere but I
think it is going to be a pain in the
sides of many of these YouTubers wow so
there's the official opinion from an
expert it'll probably cost the
influencers a lot of money but he's
skeptical if it will hold up for the
long run of course we'll see how it
plays out but the last thing I wanted to
do was not just ask a lawyer what they
thought but ask these influencers
because look whether you think this
particular lawsuit is relevant it
changes nothing about the ethics of this
situation and I wanted to hear it
straight from them and most of them
refused to comment for understandable
reasons but meet Kevin decided to
respond and here's what he said you're
being sued along with several others for
the promotion of FTX do you think you
should be liable what are your thoughts
it's terrible I think
I've lost money from
episode
Finance community
egg on the face so to speak because
because of the association with somebody
who ended up being
in fraud and it's miserable the way I
compare it is I was a real estate broker
for quite a while still am a real estate
broker and I'll oftentimes clients ask
us for vendor recommendations hey little
electrician who's a good plumber and I
had this before where 9
I'm the electrician you recommend is
great and at one time something goes
wrong because that stuff happens it
turns into the situation where the
person who's responsible is a person
making the mistake uh and I know it's
terrible because it's like hey well
Financial influencers so what how come
they didn't know we didn't have access
to financials at FTX we had hired uh
individual Representatives
sort of stuff and they tell us they do
all the vettings for us you know this is
why we hire people to help us and so we
don't have a look into the systems of
what's really going on behind the scenes
whoever else has been caught up in this
but I think that the worst case uh
scenario
of all the individual don't have access
to their deposits but do you think you
should specifically you or me uh Graham
or anybody else like who promoted it I
think the difference is between you and
Tom Brady is people kind of expect you
guys to know do you think you should be
a do you think you should be giving
recommendations if you can't do the
proper due diligence because as you said
you don't have access to these
financials and then B do you think that
given that you guys profited I'm
guessing somewhere in the realm of a
million dollars plus from these FTX
things uh do you think that you should
give back all of that money
probably somewhere
somewhere 25k is supposed to be closer
to 300 but they never paid me the last
the last so I'm probably somewhere right
around 220 I need to fact checked up but
we're close to somewhere around that uh
and uh
ultimately I agree with you I think that
that there needs to be a better there
needs to be a lot more diligence in when
sponsorships are made uh with Chris yeah
because you guys are dealing with
finances this isn't like this isn't a
Nord VPN ad where if things go wrong you
know something happens this is like if
something goes wrong people's entire
livelihoods are at stake and For Better
or For Worse you guys are seen as uh the
experts and so you guys are held to that
expert standard it's like if a doctor
recommended a pill that doesn't work and
gives you some you know gives you cancer
or something suppose it's also relevant
to what people individually say right
because individually I've always said
look crypto is extremely speculative and
that it should represent a tiny portion
of your folio if anything at all on top
of that it's also incumbent upon the
individual to take some responsibility
that we know not your keys not your
crypto that's been made abundantly clear
even with these bank failures I believe
that ultimately depositors deserve some
form of a haircut because ultimately
they choose now if I say hey go to you
know Silicon Valley bank and get a loan
and you're like I get alone here I get
all these benefits ultimately you take
that risk so it is incumbent upon the
individual to take responsibility as
well yes a doctor can refer you hey
maybe this
but the individuals aren't the experts
that's the whole problem is they rely on
Experts to help them make this decision
they don't have the luxury of spending
all day looking at finance and stuff
like this so they rely on people to make
their decisions for better or worse and
then when things go wrong uh you know
ultimately people are gonna look to the
experts in the room and say hey what
happened and if the answer is well we
just didn't do enough due diligence
sorry that's that's kind of a problem so
I think that's that's where their
questions about like giving back all the
money come from
um have have you spoken to anybody about
just giving back the money uh to the to
the people affected and once this once
all the cards are settled or all the
dust is settled so to speak and
everybody gets whatever money is left
back uh whatever deposits are left I I'm
a big fan of contributing to some sort
of Recovery Fund when it's all over not
because I feel responsible I do not feel
responsible but because I feel so
Evergreen for people who quite frankly
lost money because they either didn't
listen to the advice of not your keys
not your crypto or they put too much of
their own portfolio on you know if I go
onto a gambling website because somebody
says hey go gamble here you'll make a
lot of money and I lose money that's on
me and I want to be clear too I invested
in Block fight thinking this was going
to be a great investment I put 420 000
into block fight I lost every dime of
that because the company went bankrupt
now did I blame Anthony pompliano for
making the recommendation or suggesting
hey you could invest with my fund into
uh blog fight absolutely not because I'm
a big boy and I take personal
responsibility so I want to be very
clear just because I I suggest that hey
you know there should be and I'm happy
to work with it some form of like
basically a charity let's be clear
that's what it is it's not taking
responsibility because ultimately I
don't think anyone any influencer has to
take responsibility for what somebody
does with product advice that should
only
that responsibility should only arise
somebody actually hires somebody like
retaining an attorney hiring a doctor
for their own personal situation or
hiring a personal financial advisor
otherwise from there it's a lesson to
the whole Community we've got to be more
careful with sponsors and the viewers
have to be you know diligent about the
own their own decisions well there you
go guys those are the thoughts of meet
Kevin and I want to thank him for coming
on and maybe one day he'll start that
charity he's talking about maybe not but
until then
I just want you to understand something
the next time you're thinking of
trusting a financial influencer
these promotional deals how they work
with things like FTX is that there's a
Code associated with it that tracks
sales for example you might have heard
of somebody saying hey use code
coffeezilla or you know they have some
link right so FTX can see how many
people signed up with Kevin's link or
shax link and you know who takes
responsibility when it's time to make
money the influencer they take
responsibility for you joining their
platform that's how FTX group they paid
all these people who wanted to be
responsible for bringing you in but you
know what happens when things go wrong
suddenly they're not responsible you did
it it's on you isn't that a convenient
switch up of who brought you in at first
it was them and then you brought
yourself in you got to take
responsibility for your own actions and
I just don't think this is really
working for people anymore I think it
really just benefits the influencers and
the financial companies but hardly
anyone else it's bad for regular people
and I think there just really needs to
be new rules in place about financial
experts in the modern era but hey that's
just my opinion hashtag not Financial
advice